now i know my pleasure center is very
jazzed about this thing let's serve up
some news sunny side up
with us at the desk he dissects and
respects all things pop culture on the
iconic
everything iconic podcast please welcome
the one and only danny pellegrino
hello thank you for having me i'm so
thrilled to be here to talk about one of
my favorite topics we're talking about
scream now the scream franchise is truly
legendary drew appears in just the first
10 minutes but i feel like it's one of
the most memorable on-screen
performances
they're doing a new screen in january
drew we got to talk about the filming of
that did you know it would have such a
memorable impact
well
i
was um
sort of uh producing the movie silently
so that's basically you know trying to
get the project off the ground without a
credit
which was fine i just really believed in
the project
i thought the writing was something that
felt very different
i feel like the horror genre is very
cyclical and it had been 10 years since
nightmare and elm street which is
actually why we ended up going to west
craven who directed nightmare on elm
street
and before that it was like the john
carpenter halloween and i just thought
like every decade someone really knocks
it out of the park in this genre and i
was convinced that this script was that
so i was really passionate about it
wedding site one fab day tackled this
interesting question do i need to have
my brother as my best man
the whales people are saying no
well the answer is short this author
says no not unless you want to if your
brother isn't the right fit there are
plenty other jobs at the wedding ring
bearer a flower boy i don't know katuba
signer yeah thank you so much your
perfect best man should be whoever makes
you feel the most comfortable and
supported
and
that being said
eric
i will be your flower boy yes i will
eric
i wanted to ask you in front of
everybody
you know we are planning our wedding
right now i do
wellington and i have discussed it drew
kindly let me come on the show so i
could ask you in front of the world will
you be my best man
absolutely thank you i'd be honored to
oh my god
the hot girl walk yeah
the website toast reports that the
hashtag hot girl walk has over 5.9
million views and the concept is
credited to a tick tocker named mia and
the concept is simple go for an
hour-long walk every single day and
focus your thoughts on just three areas
number one things you're grateful for
and number two things you want to
achieve
and number three how crazy hot you are
oh yes that one just the empowering
message to yourself and shangela i mean
i would love to learn a hot girl walk
from none other than you would you teach
us how to do it what baby if y'all want
the walk let's go step in get a step
come on hill yeah there we go diva come
on oh ross oh
there you go now you're walking and you
say to yourself i am fabulous i am
fabulous i turn the party i turn the
party i love myself i love myself every
room i walk in i'm gonna make a change
variety reports
that we can get our first listen on
adele one night only it's a two-hour
concert event on cbs on november 14th
congratulations cbs for getting that one
she's set to perform some never before
heard songs oh and then there'll be a
little sit-down interview with a woman
named oprah oh my god so you know we're
gonna get right down into it and i just
have to say that i was really moved i
actually posted
on my instagram i do a thing called
sunday buffet where i sort of take the
week of instagram that i saw and curated
and put out my favorite posts and i
put out a post that she
was talking about divorce and the way
that she said it just
made me feel better about myself because
when children are involved it's the most
devastating thing i've ever gone through
and to hear adele going through
something like that it made one person
feel less alone
our first story is a big fish in the
sense of it is about the marvel universe
harry styles is joining the marvel
universe
that's right everybody's favorite boy
the coast
reports that he's on board to play
arrows the god of love and sex
i mean how perfect is this and it's
rumored that we can get a sneak peek of
arrows in the newest marvel movies the
eternals directed by chloe zhao out
november 5th now in the comics arrows
can fly he's got superhuman strength and
he has the power to
stimulate the pleasure centers
in the brain where was your mind going
sorry
um of anyone within 25 feet now i know
my pleasure center is very jazzed about
this casting
um
gp you're a marvel maven what do you
think
this makes me want to dip my toe back
into the marvel universe right
maybe pepper potts can intersect with uh
the hairy styles of it all
it's time for a pick from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
to all things i need to share with you
and today it's an incredible online tool
it's the can i binge calculator i am
here for this if you ever wanted to
binge a show but weren't sure if you had
enough time or how to do it or how to go
about it this is the tool for you you
type in the show
the amount of time you've got
and it tells you exactly how many
episodes you need to watch every day to
get it done
succession guess what you can watch it
all in one week if you did four episodes
a day that's it never seen sopranos
maybe now's the time watch it in just
one month with three episodes a day snl
easy 15 episodes a day for two months
straight and your time now that's a bit
yes ross what are you going to binge now
well i just have to say this is what i
have needed in my life because i take it
very seriously i need like 18
recommendations from friends before i
commit to a show so thank you for this
[Music]
you